Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui dans
ScienceClic, les salles anéchoïques.
L’air qui constitue notre atmosphère est formé
de molécules, principalement du diazote et du
dioxygène. Lorsqu’un objet vibre, il déplace
les molécules, et elles se poussent les unes
après les autres, formant une onde qui se propage
dans l’espace. C’est ce qu’on appelle un “son”.
Mais que se passe-t-il lorsqu'un
son rencontre un obstacle ?
La vibration des molécules d’air va tenter
de pousser les molécules de l’obstacle. Mais
celles-ci sont fortement liées, l’obstacle
est solide : il est difficile de le faire
vibrer. Comme si elles étaient reliées par des
ressorts, les molécules de l’obstacle résistent,
et repoussent les molécules d’air dans l’autre
sens. L’onde parvient en partie à faire vibrer
l’obstacle, et se transmet derrière
lui, mais elle est également réfléchie,
une partie de l’onde est renvoyée dans l’autre
sens… c’est ce qu’on appelle un “écho”.
Sur Terre, les ondes sonores
sont omniprésentes. Musique,
communications, transports... Qu’on le
veuille ou non, nous baignons au quotidien
dans une soupe de sons qui se superposent et
rebondissent sur tout ce qui nous entoure.
Imaginons un musicien qui joue de la
guitare dans une salle de concert.
La musique se propage dans tous les sens, et
arrive aux oreilles du public. Mais le son
rebondit sur les parois, de multiples fois,
et tous ces échos sont également reçus par
l’auditoire. Le son initial de la guitare
est brouillé par toutes ces ondes… On parle
de réverbération. C’est ce qui différencie
l’ambiance d’une église, de celle d’un studio.
Mais imaginons maintenant que, dans un but
scientifique, nous voulions analyser le son
rayonné par un objet. Par exemple, les ondes
produites par un haut-parleur. Dans ce cas,
les réflexions du son posent problème : elles
perturbent le signal que l’on voudrait mesurer.
Pour isoler le son brut du haut-parleur il
faudrait créer une pièce très silencieuse,
vide, et qui ne produise aucun
écho… une chambre “anéchoïque”.
Dans cette vidéo nous allons tenter de
construire une chambre anéchoïque étape
par étape. Pour commencer, rendons
la pièce parfaitement silencieuse…
Au départ, la salle n’est pas silencieuse. Notre
ordinateur par exemple fait un peu de bruit.
Une première amélioration serait de déplacer
le matériel de mesure dans une autre pièce,
pour éviter qu’on ne l’entende.
Elle servira de salle de pilotage.
Le silence n’est toutefois pas encore
parfait. D’autres bruits proviennent de
l’extérieur : les voitures, les passants, les
avions. Pour s’en affranchir, on va remplacer
les parois par du béton très épais - que les
ondes ont du mal à traverser - et on ajoute
une couche d’isolant acoustique, un matériau
très efficace pour absorber les ondes sonores.
Le passage des camions, ou des trains,
provoque également des vibrations du sol
qui se répercutent dans la pièce. Pour s’isoler
de ces vibrations, on va surélever la structure
et la placer sur des “plots anti-vibratiles”. De
gros ressorts destinés à absorber les vibrations.
Enfin, on construit une deuxième
“boîte”, tout autour de la salle,
pour finir de l’isoler complètement. Cette
épaisseur contribue notamment à isoler la salle
des variations de température à l’extérieur.
Le son se déplace plus vite dans l’air chaud,
car les molécules y sont plus agitées.
Si on imagine un jour en plein été,
les bords de la salle risqueraient de
se réchauffer par rapport au centre,
et les ondes sonores s’y propageraient
différemment. En isolant la pièce, on s’assure
qu’elle garde une température homogène, et que
les ondes se déplacent partout de la même façon.
A ce stade, notre salle est très silencieuse,
on l’a isolée de tous les bruits parasites
provenant de l’extérieur. Mais il
reste un problème : les ondes se
réfléchissent toujours sur les murs et
brouillent le son que l’on veut mesurer.
Pour régler ce dernier problème, on va
surélever le haut-parleur pour le placer
au centre de la pièce, et recouvrir toutes
les parois par des centaines de “dièdres”.
Ce sont des objets triangulaires
constitués d’un matériau poreux,
idéal pour absorber les sons. Quand
une onde rencontre une paroi, tous ces
“zigzags” démultiplient la surface de matériau
absorbant. L’onde rebondit de multiples fois,
piégée à l’intérieur de ces structures, et
se dissipe de plus en plus à chaque rebond.
On a construit une chambre “anéchoïque”.
Contrairement à une pièce classique,
le son s’y propage librement
dans toutes les directions,
et ne rencontre aucun obstacle comme s’il
s'agissait d’une salle infiniment grande.
Au Laboratoire de Mécanique et d’Acoustique
de Marseille, les chercheurs acousticiens
disposent d’un équipement unique : un complexe
original de 3 grandes salles anéchoïques,
aux performances exceptionnelles, configurées
chacune pour des applications différentes.
La première salle du LMA est dédiée à la
perception auditive. On y étudie le système
auditif humain. Cette chambre est spécialement
conçue pour pouvoir placer une personne, ou un
mannequin équipé de micros, au centre de la pièce.
La personne est ainsi isolée de l’extérieur,
on parle parfois de “chambre sourde”. On y
étudie l'intelligibilité de la parole. Ou
notre perception du son en 3 dimensions. On tente
également de caractériser nos ressentis en termes
de préférences ou de gêne face à différents sons.
Ou encore notre perception de l’intensité sonore,
ou de la hauteur du son. Ces
travaux permettent de mieux
comprendre notre audition et son fonctionnement.
La deuxième salle du Laboratoire est une chambre
semi-anéchoïque : le sol n’est pas absorbant,
le son peut s’y réfléchir. Cette configuration
est plus pratique pour certaines applications
de recherche, et pour les industriels.
On peut par exemple poser de gros objets,
comme une voiture ou une machine à laver, et
mesurer l’intensité du bruit qu’ils produisent,
en vue d’évaluer leurs performances,
ou leur conformité en termes de
nuisances sonores. Ces produits sont
destinés à être utilisés sur un sol,
et il est donc judicieux de prendre en compte les
réflexions des ondes qui participent elles aussi
au bruit total qu’entendra l’utilisateur. Sous
la salle, une cabine communique par une trappe,
et permet également de placer une source sonore
pour mesurer le son qui traverse un objet. On
peut de la sorte déterminer si un matériau
est un bon isolant acoustique par exemple.
Enfin, la troisième salle du laboratoire,
très grande et très performante,
est principalement dédiée à des
projets de recherche fondamentale,
et a pour objectif d’y développer
un système unique au monde…
Lorsqu’on entend un son, celui-ci est
constitué de plusieurs fréquences,
vibrant entre 20 et 20 000 fois par seconde. Les
hautes fréquences correspondent à des sons aigus,
et les basses fréquences à des sons plus graves.
Mais plus un son est grave, plus sa
longueur d’onde est grande. Et en
dessous de 100 vibrations par seconde, la
longueur d’onde dépasse plusieurs mètres,
et les dièdres sont trop petits en comparaison,
ils ne parviennent pas à piéger l’onde sonore. Les
sons les plus graves rebondissent sur les parois,
comme s’il s’agissait d’une salle ordinaire.
Pour pallier ce problème, et créer une salle qui
soit anéchoïque même pour les fréquences basses,
les chercheurs du LMA travaillent sur le
développement d’un système unique au monde.
L’idée est de compléter le revêtement des parois
par 64 haut-parleurs et 128 microphones destinés
à agir en temps réel pour annuler les échos
dans les basses fréquences. Lorsqu’un son
grave rebondit contre une paroi, il est détecté
par les microphones, qui ordonnent aussitôt aux
haut-parleurs de produire une onde identique,
mais opposée. On contrôle activement les ondes
qui n’ont pas pu être absorbées, et on les annule
en leur superposant de nouvelles ondes, opposées.
On parle de contrôle “actif”. Le même principe
que dans les casques anti-bruit. Si l’air vibre
dans un sens, le dispositif va aussitôt réagir
et pousser les molécules dans l’autre sens, pour
annuler leur vibration. Ce projet très ambitieux,
visible à l’échelle internationale, est pour
l’instant en cours de développement, mais la salle
est déjà pré-câblée pour accueillir ce système, et
les chercheurs ont franchi des étapes prometteuses
dans l’espoir d’une première mondiale.
En résumé, une chambre anéchoïque remplit deux
fonctions : elle crée un espace silencieux,
isolé de l’extérieur, et minimise les
réflexions du son sur ses parois. Une
telle salle est un équipement de
référence pour les acousticiens. Il
en existe d’ailleurs des analogues pour
étudier les ondes électromagnétiques.
Les 3 salles du Laboratoire de Mécanique et
d’Acoustique de Marseille répondent à de multiples
problématiques. Scientifiques : on y étudie
le rayonnement de sources sonores complexes,
comme des instruments de musique, mais aussi
le système auditif humain, et notre perception
du son. Techniques : on y caractérise le
son rayonné par des objets industriels ou
encore la transparence acoustique de certains
matériaux innovants. Et des problématiques de
santé publique, pour étudier les nuisances
et la pollution sonore, ou encore améliorer
les performances des implants cochléaires,
destinés aux personnes atteintes de surdité.
Contrairement à ce qu’on entend parfois
il est possible d’y rester plusieurs
heures sans problème, c’est ce que font les
scientifiques lors de leurs expériences,
mais certaines personnes peuvent être sensibles,
et troublées par ce silence presque absolu.
Pour finir, le LMA développe un système unique
au monde, une chambre anéchoïque hybride,
qui sera dotée d’un système de contrôle
actif, dans l’espoir d'étudier en temps
réel des sources basses fréquences.
Chose impossible à l’heure actuelle…
Cette vidéo a été réalisée en partenariat
avec EchoSciences Provence-Alpes-Côte d’Azur,
dans le cadre des Vidéos EchoScientifiques. Elle
a été écrite en collaboration avec le Laboratoire
de Mécanique et d’Acoustique de Marseille
sous les conseils de Cédric Pinhède. Pour
en savoir plus sur les chambres anéchoïques du
LMA, rendez-vous sur la chaîne d’Echosciences.